ok poi in giro caricando da qualcosa che
ricaricano è uscita l'espansione di
signor tv dove c'è questo squalo grosso
grosso forte chiamato megalodon te non
lo trovi in giro a caso lo trovi solo se
fai determinati passaggi per richiamarlo
ve la spiego alla velocissima perché se
non ho capito una mazza devi andare da
questo pelato che un tizio che sta su un
isolati da un megafono revocare il mega
rodomonte bisogna essere in 5 la quinta
persona la devi reclutare tra le forme
degli altri pirati che trovi in gioco
sperando che non ti sparino in faccia
quando gli chiedi aiuto esiste questo
oggetto che un megafono che serve per
parlare con le altre navi e dire
aiutateci a evocare lo squalo una volta
che siete in cinque quindi potete votare
lo squalo tornate dal tipo operato che
vi dà un tamburo dovete portare la sua
musica è non smettere di suonare finché
non arrivata in un preciso punto della
mappa
tutti e cinque vi mettete a suonare
quella melodia e richiamate il megalodon
è un casino ve l'ho spiegata proprio
velocissimo perché se non capito una
mazza in tutto il video detto questo
buona visione io ho comperato nel menu
perché eccolo c'è un tipo seduto al bar
togli te no io non so ma è svenuto con
la birra è lui che uccidere da questa ma
sei sicuro che lui e lui ma si viene con
la birra in mano sta punto pirata non mi
sembra tanto affidabile mi scusi
guardano saranno dietro pietra ti prego
guardano e si regge in piedi da posto
c'è un tizio conosciuto come meri
merrick a sud ovest di shark bay che
andare sotto la veste di shark bay sono
già sulla nave io sono già in auto non
sono già in autostrada come si fa per
dire a me fa parlare bones a questo tipo
di barili esplosivi davanti alla nostra
nave che se andiamo avanti cadiamo
subito al posto di parlare di quali di
barili per raccogliere cosa che ci
servono i barili davanti è invece di
pensare i barili pensa le altre cose
prima di salire sulla barca cosa ti ha
detto abbiamo dei barili davanti i sei
tu che hai fatto di lorenzo ha chiesto
squadrato via
l'oro è sparato su un'isola non mi sono
sparato in alto però va bene
sono andata all'isola riga non vedo
davanti perché andando addosso sono
tranquillo vai avanti non c'è niente
dove sei
no per niente a legaccio uno scoglio
fermi ma finisce ok allora cos'è sta
roba è un mega come ferro al megafono
però danno per parlare con le altre nove
chiedere aiuto
vai vai chiedi aiuto tu hai altra vede
prego sulla nave fermo a sinistra kanye
west che trovano un po legame con alfa
subite mega mega loft in inglese
eccole 1 st lichtsteiner è pronta è
arrivata la foto mi riguarda sembra che
ride per spacciare dell'hard della droga
hey man che unit mi si ma chiedetevi mi
devi parlare in faccia con il backup
quello che sto facendo e sordo di
metterlo nell'orecchio che gli arriva
più alto cioè serve aiuto mima la parola
aiuto mima la parola aiuto allora ci
serve è bello risveglio almeno un tipo
sveglio la fai we need help to take the
big fish ragazzi mandando regala ancora
c'è un uomo freddo presente che sta
fischiettando e sic li senti ebit a
scelta megafono dandone capone dove lo
premio si fa allora l'inspirazione capo
non per la gara fin dall altra eccolo mi
senti grazie mille
ma senza il tamburo di musica la
profonda da vedere eccolo e dobbiamo
prendere ritmo da lui e portando sulla
barca ora viste tutti e tamburello basta
con lo potete vedere cosa si stia
lavorando c'è qualcuno che sulla nave
cantava d'amico venti minuti poi lite in
cancrena qualcuno e sulla nave con la
musica
io a partire redini di voi ve dicono se
per un ritmo a un centimetro della
votazione dello squalo dovrebbero
venivano dalla barca mi chiamo questo
[ __ ] canto andiamo a votare stop e io
vado per loro frank vaio loro potremo
entrare mi si vuol dire faccio il backup
il backup della canzone se ci andai a
tieni la musica della musica dove della
mappa ok quale ti 26 domanda di 26
perché latin il nome della della sua
amata 20 se non l'ho mai capito lo dice
ma non ho capito come mandare al 26
cioè il megalodon the ai limiti del mare
sul 26 sulla te canzone brutta voglio
dovrebbe partire di buona musica epica
quanti volta in volta
beh almeno come almeno tutto sto casino
per far arrivare a scuola gigante che ci
ammazza se prima la ragazzina era ancora
in metro eretta spera ancora altre bye
bye bye bye bye ci siamo detti ok
noi di san carlo dove posso dare tutti e
cinque i voti prendi prendi il tempo lo
re lo aiutano pietra dove te perché mi
fa malissimo
siete vi vedo arrivate siamo in tre lai
venite anche voi facevo in one direction
proponessero suonando e mi fa malissimo
la mano vi prego a teramo alla mano ok
siete state suonando fatta no abbiamo
tutti sulla punta della barca perché
normalmente sarà appiccicati quale ga
occhio conosce
raga
la partita perfetta
e tu cosa ma cosa c'è di vero
mentalmente negli anni di far aderire e
grosso e grosso amici bisogna fare
bisogna colpirli i cannoni canonica non
avete le palle che ne parliamo chiama e
palle eccole qua a prua a poppa quando
carica la nave dove spera gli in bocca
madonna mai grossissimo bravo a caricare
porcaccia vacca occhio vista questa qua
mettete che carica pescara dove dietro
da subito è quella grossa l'occhio sta
caricando gli sbarrò no aspetta non era
scarica madonna che male mi ha fatto
male dalla barca cazzo farsi poi gli si
può sognare in qualche modo soprattutto
per fare sotto sotto si sia arrivati
arrivare a rivara to mangiate ha fatto
malissimo
ok acqua passalacqua posto ma lo
batteremo mai laga gigantesco sono
sparati quando ci carica vista per
ricaricare a 33 sentire penso almeno due
palle di cannone quando carica
bravo a un tema male
anch'io anch'io sarà panchina sono
qualche aiuterò la pesca
questa è la mia più brutta fobia giudice
sono tre punti e siamo
questa è la mia follia più brutta
nell'oceano trovare un micro conte ok e
delle scuole per l'anno scheda o dio c'è
il fucile da cecchino con la bottiglia
sta caricando non lo vedo in aragami
annullarlo io lo spero e sparato gava
stati a rega impossibile da fermare
qualcosa ma è ucciso a regà non va bene
così e non riesco a beccarlo è non
essere caratura affamati di ancoraggio
ma ancora ma nome è difficilissimo
telefono fissi non è fortissimo
veramente ancora ritrovate oggi arriva a
garanzia riberto peccato peccato l'altra
nave erika b libri comuni italiani da
noi qualche siamo o chiocchio da mariga
non è possibile e dolore
peccato lasciato cazzo beccato volte vai
sta caricando cavalca e non ho l asse
aspetta noi compete non servono per la
quanto avuto più l'acqua se ci carica
tutto per l'arco di tutto per l'acqua
siamo da soli io e te cavalcano preso
ragazzi tornate perché siamo messi male
si è trasformato da messi bene a tenere
la mia carriera con la sua parte e anche
sull'ultimo puro spirito la scuola
primaria è morto per loro è morto poi
morto dai no mi hanno lasciato della
musichetta non ci credevo anche di
musica ma come morto è morto è morto ma
non è morto a nova e non c'è niente lega
tumori player ma va ma figurati se è
morto così ce l'avrebbe detto sono scemi
ecco dinamo e questa è stata la nostra
avventura con lo squalo grosso picross
purtroppo non siamo riusciti ad
ucciderlo se muore lo squalo rimane
proprio con il corpo morto e mezzo
all'oceano e non è stato così si vede
che è scappato non sappiamo bene per
quale motivo credo che siamo morti
troppe volte non lo so in rada non so
precisamente cosa è successo visto che
l'hanno fatta ancora in pochi st
missione insomma ci abbiamo provato eri
sticazzi ragazzi spero che il video sia
piaciuto come al solito si ricicla soft
commento e mi piace anche vari social
comitato descrizione iscrivetevi se non
siete iscritti riceviamo e figure bari
[Musica]